Simplify xy to the
negative 2 power times 2x
squared over y squared
to the fourth power.
So let's see what
we can do over here.
So let's think about this
part of our expression first.
If I have x over y
to the n-th power,
we know that this is the same
thing as x to the n-th over y
to the n-th.
So let's apply that
right over here.
So this expression, 2x squared
over y squared to the fourth,
this is going to be the
same thing as 2x squared
to the fourth power over y
squared to the fourth power.
And of course, we
still have our xy
to the negative
2 power out here.
And actually, let me
simplify that as well.
We know that if we have x
times y to the n-th power,
this is the same thing as taking
each of the powers of each
of the x and the y and
then taking the product.
This is x to the n
times y to the n.
And actually, if
you just expand--
if you multiply
xy times itself n
times you'll see why
this actually works out
because you'll have x multiplied
by itself x times if you
rearrange the product and y
multiplied by itself n times.
So if we use that
same property here,
xy to the negative
2, that's going
to be the same exact thing
as x to the negative 2 times
y to the negative 2.
Now what can we simplify?
Well, we can use this property
again right over here.
We have 2x squared raised
to the fourth power.
So that's going to be
the same thing as 2
to the fourth power times x
squared to the fourth power.
And we can do it
in the denominator.
y squared to the fourth
power-- actually,
we're going to use a different
property in the denominator.
We just have y squared
to the fourth power.
We know that if
we have x to the n
and then raise that
to the m-th power,
this is the same thing
as x to the n times m.
So y squared and
then raising that
to the fourth power
that's going to be
equal to y to the
2 times 4 power,
or y to the eighth power.
And of course, out here we
have x to the negative 2 times
y to the negative 2.
Now, let's think a little bit
about what x to the negative 2
and y to the negative 2 mean.
x to the negative 2 just
means 1 over x squared.
y to the negative 2 just
means 1 over y squared.
So let's rewrite it like that.
So this is the same thing
as 1 over x squared times 1
over y squared.
So we could just write that
as 1 over x squared y squared.
That and that are
completely equivalent.
So let's see what we can do now.
So we have one last
thing we could-- well,
we don't have one last thing.
We have a few more
things to worry about.
We have x squared and
then we're raising that
to the fourth power.
Once again, we can use
this property right here.
This is going to be x
to the 2 times 4 power.
So this part right over here--
I'll do it in a new color.
This part right
over here is going
to simplify to x to the
eighth power 2 times 4.
This part right over here is
going to 2 to the fourth power.
To the third is 8 so
2 to the fourth is 16.
So that is 16.
And so our whole expression
has now simplified to--
and if we multiply
it times this,
we multiply it
times 1 so I'm going
to multiply these two fractions.
My numerator 16 times
x to the eighth.
And all of that over
I have x squared.
And then I'm going to
have a y squared times a y
to the eighth.
What is y squared
times y to the eighth?
y squared times y to the eighth.
We have the same base so
we can add the exponents.
We're taking the
product so it's to going
to be y to the 2 plus 8,
or y to the 10th power.
So y squared times
y the eighth is
going to be y to the 10th power.
And we're almost there.
We have one more
thing we can simplify.
We have x to the
eighth over x squared.
And we know-- I'll just write
the general property-- if we
have x to the m over
x to the n, this
is equal to x to
the m minus n power.
So x to the eighth over x
squared, that over there
will simplify to x to
the 8 minus 2 power
or x to the sixth power.
And so our whole expression has
now simplified to 16 times x
to the sixth all of that
over y to the 10th power.
And we are done.